armelle lettre o bruce avance mais
peut-être un peu plus lentement qu'elle
ne devrait quand on sait quels sont
leurs façons d'opérer il est vrai sur
d'autres théâtres est ce qu'on peut
parler d'un début d'enlisement de la
russie en ukraine aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on est dans une période où l'on sait
pas exactement ce que font les russes de
toute manière et que même doivent
s'adapter en fonction des éléments
qu'ils ont eu à leur disposition
je dirai au niveau diplomatique il ya
quand même eu deux sommets qui était
assez important qui était le sommet de
versailles rencontre des pays européens
et puis un autre sommet qui était celui
du ministre lavrov qui rencontrait son
homologue ukrainien antalya en turquie
alors il l'avait jamais rencontrée il
n'avait jamais accepté de reconnaître
qu'ils pouvaient se parler ç'a permis
peut-être aussi à vladimir poutine à
moment donné de d'attendre de voir ce
qui pouvait en sortir et de ne pas
donner des injonctions dur sur le
terrain
d'autre part sur le terrain on à la
météo qui joue il fait maintenant très
très froid en ukraine on est en dessous
des normales saisonnières mais du coup
on est en dessous des -10
alors ce qui a un avantage pour les
chars parce que du coup ils ont les
terrains sont moins gadoue et donc du
coup ils ont une capacité à monter plus
rapidement mais en revanche ça va être
plus compliqué pour les combats en
urbain dans la mesure où il fait froid
ils font pas forcément équipés pour et
quand vous êtes dans un char et dans ces
cas là c'est pas quand vous êtes arrivé
en dans la ville vous savez aussi très
froid parce que ces conducteurs de froid
donc tout ça effectivement joue en
faveur d'une peut-être d'une méta rhji
russe mais ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
quelles vont être les ordres derrière
c'est à dire un moment donné ce que
vladimir poutine va dire quoi qu'il en
soit je veux qu'ils aient et donc quel
que soit le coût que cela représente
mais blindé qui avancent progressivement
vers la ville je les fais rentrer à
l'intérieur de la ville même si à une
guérilla et j'accepte d'avoir ces
risques là parce que je veux que kiev
tombe première chose est ce que on va
plutôt se retrouver un moment donné sur
un accord et on en reste là où est ce
que les troupes russes dans ces cas là
vont être amenés à être renfort sur le
pays en lisant maintenant qu'on a passé
une première étape on sait qu'on a des
morts on sait maintenant que il ya eu
des des cercueils qui rompt pas pu être
livrés donc on a mis des poches en
plastique pour mettre les corps l'armée
russe en a rapporté donc dans ce cas là
est ce qu'on prépare l'opinion publique
et qu'on va quand même sur une guerre
plus longue et plus dure on ne sait pas
quelles vont être les solutions mais
elles sont toutes là sur le terrain en
tout cas rester avec nous un mail
charrier merci beaucoup de